I'll figure it out you have any glue
these [ __ ] electrician video like
what's keyed in with me glue
Elmer's ah crazy girl gorilla
somebody hit me with another glue and
I'll [ __ ] give you ten thousand
dollars cash I have it in my car uh
crazy clip no we won't I always see you
said crazy [ __ ]
here we go ah you know what it's close
enough whatever like that I think that's
is that legal I think that looks great
Wendy you happy with that
ladies and gentlemen Dane Cook yeah dude
what's up man so you met Scott yep my
co-host yeah
um
this is a long time coming man like you
were one of the first guys that I wanted
to get on here
um
because you've been so generous with
your time with your support and
um really without you I would not have
launched into
uh a comedy career the way that I did
and have you ever do people really know
like how that kind of transpired and
where we ended up yapping well I never
shut up about it
I've heard I've heard fragments and flex
and I was always like so moved that you
acknowledge that you know we had that
time but I don't know if I've ever
really held court with you to talk about
like how that night was meaningful for
both of us because I was also in a very
convoluted place in my life and time wow
yeah I mean just to give people The
Cliff Notes um it was when the first
tiny Rumblings of the press machine uh
revved up for
the Jackass 3D movie yeah that movie
came out and I want to say October but
we're back like a few months before that
and uh like maybe August maybe even July
2010 2010 and I showed up for this uh
young Hollywood at the Four Seasons
Hotel they had a whole Suite rented out
using it as a studio they were cycling
people through doing interviews and when
I showed up for mine they said oh dude
Dane Cook's in there go ahead and just
barge right into his interview it'll be
hilarious yeah so I walk in by the way
we found footage of this too they say
barged by the way that's usually not the
word that they tee you up with right hey
you should pop in and say hi but usually
maybe for you it's barged yeah so I know
when I sit down it was the first time we
ever met it was uh you know a pleasant
experience and I said you know dude Dane
I've done stand up a couple times and
and it's something I really want to dive
into and you said great cool next week
we can jump on stage
and like I figured after the interview
was over maybe like you would just you
know it was great to say that on camera
but sure enough flip service Hollywood
yeah when the cameras I got enough of it
to know I didn't want to be that but
yeah when the cameras were no longer
rolling you you were like yeah seriously
man here let me give you my number and
let's plan this out yeah because I I
quickly identified something that we
talked a little bit about which was
I knew a lot of people that were very
talented that wanted to figure out how
to uh recalibrate to stand up and
sometimes in the community that's like
really frowned upon for whatever reason
they think this is what they think a lot
of people in the community you're a
really good drummer but you want to play
guitar who the [ __ ] do you think you are
right and I assume if you're good at one
instrument you're probably good at
entertaining people maybe in a couple of
other instruments and I had also gone
through the same thing of like I came up
I came up in kind of like a way that I
broke ahead of a pack
and because I was using this new social
media element I was somehow not
legitimate I was hitting a button and Ah
that's interesting circumventing so by
the time this dude comes in the door and
I'm a bit of an energy Vibe guy myself I
was like oh I I identify that
I know where this guy's at and also I'd
known like guys like Bert Kreischer who
I was telling you I sat at hojos in
Times Square in 95 and he was coming out
of a time when he was the Rolling Stones
The Machine Party the comics were being
shitty to him like he's not one of us
he's not legit he came from a uh hype
article or something so
I was like I just I I was like I'm a fan
and I I felt like
you were really sincere in that moment I
wanted to just return that sincerity
well I appreciate it so much and I
remember
every bit of it like I spent in the next
week just writing material I was even
going to like these hole in the wall
open mics to practice it I I was uh you
know rehearsing it writing it rewrite
and spent that whole week just like
coming up with this crappy little set
and um you know we showed up at the the
uh Hollywood improv you went on and I
think it was like Sarah Silverman and
then you and then me and I just couldn't
have been more nervous I did my set I
remember uh my first joke was um I've
been clean and sober since Johnny
Knoxville pulled an intervention on me
and you know you have a problem when
your interventionist is Johnny Knoxville
and uh you know
it was what it was you know I did this
thing and then what was crazy was that
after which which for me it was funny
well not only funny but like my brain
always goes to like if there's truth in
your whatever
I respond to that even more than if you
said something very funny that was only
observational like response is the
response but like you're saying
something really real within a shell of
something humorous so that was cool
that's that's how it's been like all
along it's just been like 100 like my my
reality you know how how comedians get
pissed when you come on and become a
comedian from acting do do actors get
pissed when you are a comedian then you
become an actor I mean is it kind of the
same thing are they like hey welcome No
in fact like when I just very quickly
when I dovetailed into some dramatic
stuff or stuff away from Comedy they
were if anything people were excited
like oh you're going to bring an element
to this scene or this script that's
crazy maybe we didn't you're doing
something dramatic but if we need
something comedic they kind of look to
you go like you you probably have an
idea but the comedy world as you now
know
um you know there's a lot of thorn
patches and there's you know it's more
competitive than what you would see
exterior as far as like you think it's a
community of just funny people just
it's just not right I wanted it to be
that too for the longest time but it's
just not and so you can find when you
find somebody who Keys into you and is
like
take a breath
you know come back you know somebody
said to me really recently dude I've
been getting beat up by so many kind of
comics and you know I think I'm gonna
quit I was just like just do me a favor
don't quit tonight okay yeah based on
this conversations give it give it
another night give it one more shot
you'll feel a little differently with
some new inspiration or whatever but
that moment and two years later have you
and I talk about it and acknowledge it
I'm just I said it last night man I'm
proud of you I'm proud of you look what
you've done you're so entrepreneurial
and I'm sure a lot of those people that
maybe or maybe not are in your book or
um are probably thinking like man I wish
I had been more of a friend of that guy
so Dane's the reason why I have a tour
managing job too yeah well
thank you yeah
also real quick before you tell me that
story I'm the one who released Wendy
let dogs out of the van and hope that
maybe they found love in Peru and so
Wendy you're welcome and Scott yeah yeah
wait what no no I missed I'm his tour
manager and so like uh that he he
brought me on like nine years ago got it
because by proxy it was like okay that's
cool that's very nice man I love that
yeah so I do the first set and now keep
in mind Dane did his set then he
introduced me and then I did my set oh
we're a tag team yeah oh [ __ ] okay you
brought me on and uh with vicious
cruelty like I had left uh I had left a
bottle of water on the piano at The
Improv and you're like you're like does
anybody like have a like a hazmat suit
to remove this something rather like
anybody want herpes that it was it was
it was it was it like every like without
fail like on stage Dane would be like
just vicious yeah amazing of love that
you only get from a comic that really
cares about you that's cool but then he
gets off stage watches me perform my set
actually Karen to pay attention to it
and then when I got off stage we sat
down in the restaurant and joining The
Improv and I'll never forget it like I
sat down and Dane said
all right I'm not sending you back to
the drawing board and I was like
processing it's like like wait okay so
like the he said what I'm concerned with
is your your delivery you know more than
your material your material is like
working you know
just uh you're so like tense and like
you know nervous and I'm like well [ __ ]
I was nervous you know like thank God
yeah if my cat was nervous he was like I
need you to relax I need to relax
just like just relax you know I'd like
be more conversation right be more
conversational and just give birth you
don't have to be the thing people know
of you or think you are you you have to
have some Showmanship but I was really
just trying to tell them like dude
you're [ __ ] revved yeah get revved
years ago Metallica said when somebody
asked why why are you now doing more
ballads he goes the hard stuff rocks
harder when you slow it down a beat and
it was like I took that into
consideration in my own career and I
think I was trying to let you know that
like you can't come out of the gate and
[ __ ] well yeah and it was you said
you wanted to that
seem to be conversational like let it
don't make it be so much of a
performance but rather that you're
talking like yeah natural remember the
audience yeah trying to tell you like
you can build into performance pieces
but sometimes like in the own narration
of your act you gotta like that's when
you can like cool down a little bit when
you're set I I did that was a Wednesday
night and uh and I was just so energized
that you had been been supportive that
that you had been uh you know like like
what you told me put so much wind in my
sails that I arranged for that Friday
night two nights later to be at the
Laugh Factory to go to go work on this
material some more yeah yeah and it just
so turned out that uh
it was you and then it was me we
repeated the same exercise so after
myself put him on after me I wanted to
learn everything all at once yeah
that night I come off stage and and we
sit down together and you said okay now
you're too relaxed now you just look
straight back he said now you're like
straight [ __ ] lethargic you gotta
remember this is a performance you know
like you got to be an animated version
of yourself right because I was trying
to relax you're like relaxing too much
and and it was uh then the next night
Saturday night we [ __ ] did it again
it was like this this uh every [ __ ]
night on you know we did it regularly
yeah we did and you always took the time
to to watch my [ __ ] and sit down and
give me notes and it meant the world
hardest
um part about like when your comic
especially once you know you've made it
and people go like what should I do and
my whole thing is like it's not so much
me telling you I'm trying to always
protect your integrity when I'm Mentor
even Comics now I'm like I'm not going
to tell you how to be funny I'm not
going to tell you to take that out or
add that in I'm just going to try to
help you to figure out in some way the
fundamentals to get to whatever the
truth is that you are because that's
what they're going to respond to even
more than the jokes believe it or not
the jokes are not what they're it's
musicality
it's I've got a secret
I'm gonna let you know what it is in a
second hold up there's a lot of hype
there's a lot of things happening under
the surface I came up watching a guy
Johnny Carson on The Tonight Show when a
joke went bad
that's when he was [ __ ] amazing when
the crowd didn't react
it's like a facial expression like it
was like oh that's where you're alive
not in the formulaic stuff that you've
prepared yeah in the moments that
something happened somebody drops the
glass and then maybe somebody gets to
know you within that moment so I was
getting to
see you in real time and again like I I
want to be like um
recognizing pretty quick that like I
really wanted to give you some genuine
love and friendship I just felt
something from you maybe I even probably
knew a little bit of your story to
understand kind of like where you were
coming from but I remember night tonight
whenever we could shoot the [ __ ] about
it I was always like my goal tonight
with Stevo
um middle name Gilchrist
is I always wanted to call him that by
the way I was like okay
um was to try to tell him a little
something that I recognized that was
good and maybe something that was like
all right that needs a little bit yeah I
mean because let's be clear like I I was
doing this basically for the first time
yeah it was I wasn't destroying he was
floundering it no no no he was he was he
was recognizable and it was like they he
had a lot more work to do than somebody
who's brand new yeah because they had
assumptions he made me go up in front of
2 000 people foreign
will film the entire thing yeah it's
called Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and if you go on Amazon and
type in Stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole and Order yourself a bottle
you'd be really helping me because right
now we're ranked number 30 on all of
Amazon and if you buy a bottle we might
go up the ladder and that would mean a
lot so please get on Amazon and buy
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude